on october 4th 2020 when covid19 was
raging american schools were mostly
shuttered and vaccines were believed to
be years away a team of top researchers
at the world's most prestigious
universities including stanford's jay
bhattacharya harvard's martin kaldorf
and oxford sunetra gupta published the
great barrington declaration a
controversial open letter challenging
the official u.s response of lockdowns
and government control of ever larger
parts of the economy and everyday life
recognizing that covet overwhelmingly
affected elderly americans and others
with specific identifiable health
conditions they called for a policy of
focused protection in which the
vulnerable would be kept safe and the
rest of us especially children and young
adults would be able to get on with our
lives the response at the very highest
levels of government was quick and
draconian francis collins then the
director of the national institutes of
health wrote a private email to anthony
fauci which was later obtained through a
foia request denouncing bhattacharya
kaldorf and gupta as fringe
epidemiologists who deserve to be the
subject of a media takedown
big tech outlets like facebook and
google followed suit suppressing our
ideas falsely deeming them
misinformation says bhattacharya a
professor of medicine at stanford who
also holds a phd in economics i started
getting calls from reporters asking me
why i wanted to let the virus rip when i
had proposed nothing of the sort i was
the target of racist attacks and death
threats
reason sat down with bhattacharya to
talk about what it was like to be at the
very center of an official effort to
suppress heterodox thinking about the
pandemic why he believes he and his
great barrington declaration co-authors
have been vindicated and whether the
public health establishment can ever
recover from ongoing revelations of
incompetence malfeasance and politically
motivated decision making he also
discusses how the centralization of
science funding encourages dangerous
group thing why he believes in mrna
vaccines but remains staunchly
anti-mandate and why he stopped wearing
masks a long time ago jay bhattacharya
thanks for talking to reason a pleasure
to be here nick
so at this point in time how bad have we
handled covet
i think we've made absolutely
catastrophic mistakes uh the the the
problems have been
just
manifold uh and they've been exacerbated
by essentially making it so that you
couldn't dissent
that that the cost of dissenting against
the policy was so high that most people
decided not to do so and that's that was
in the trump administration and the
bible administration i mean something
separate from that um you have talked
about um uh the
response to covet as the biggest public
health mistake we've ever made
you've said the harm to people is
catastrophic let's unpack that a little
bit um
you know when we say the harm to people
is catastrophic obviously you know
there's a million people in america who
are dead that's catastrophic
what would it have been like if we had
responded differently would we have you
know seen like a tenth of that number or
how do you calculate that i mean i think
um
cove is a bad disease i don't think it
was possible to avoid a lot of deaths
from kovid
both here and abroad
the the issue is uh taking advantage of
the the scientific evidence about who's
most vulnerable to covet and acting on
that
instead of acting in the way we did
which was to
in a sense to assume that all people
were equally
at risk and there and thereby the only
thing we can do is to stop the spread of
the disease to act as to to suppress the
disease so would you i mean is it
possible that have we done something
different we would have had about the
same number of deaths i mean i think we
would have had fewer deaths okay i don't
think it would have been
you know 10 of those i think if we still
would have had a considerable amount of
death i do think less than we had um but
uh
but that's only if you're looking at
covet alone if you're looking more
broadly at public health uh i think we
would have actually done better in terms
of the total number of deaths not just
from kobe but from other sources can you
talk about that can you quantify you
know not the specific cove of deaths but
then the kind of things that attend to
it and you know as well as is it even
possible to calculate future whether
it's economic harm psychological harm or
health harm yeah i mean i think these
are this is a difficult it's a difficult
task i mean
but that is what public health is
supposed to be about right yeah it is
about cost benefits of various kinds of
reactions i mean you aren't even allowed
to say cost benefits back in the back in
2020 of course but uh but i think but
that's exactly right i mean public
health is supposed to take a holistic
view
of of human well-being not just simply
deaths from one cause but
health from lots of other causes so just
to give you some sense of the numbers um
the uh the the number of people that
have been thrown into poverty worldwide
and this is a world bank estimate
something on the order of 100 million
people right so over over the last 20 30
years a billion people have been lifted
out of poverty
a hundred million people are now at two
dollars a day or less of income
additional people that would would have
otherwise and and that has led to
starvation so uh in
2021 march 2021 the u.n estimated that
almost 230 000 children have died of
starvation as a consequence of
essentially the the pandemic responsible
the poverty
uh
as and
that wasn't just in south asia alone
there's tens of millions of of people
that have starved essentially as a
consequence of the economic harm and
we're talking in poor parts of the world
right in richer parts of the world we
let go of basic preventative activity
prevention that would have
would have saved lives so for instance
um uh women showing up with breast
cancer
later stage breast cancer should have
been caught earlier because they skipped
mammograms um or same thing with
colonoscopies for both men and women
diabetes management
the psychological harms are catas are
also catastrophic how do you quantify
that though i i mean i think the logic
makes sense but do we can we even
estimate how many how many women died of
breast cancer because they had to delay
you know by three months or by 18 months
basic um you know kind of evacuations
there are these like uh
they're these like models that people
will do but i think some of that has to
play out over time because you know it's
not all baked in the cake we can we can
you know up our efforts to
to do a screening another example of
this is uh is schooling right so
uh in california where i was uh where i
live
for almost 18 months my kids had you
know very very irregular school zoom
school um and you know i could help
supplement that
at home but but there's a lot of poor
families that can't
the there's a literature on
the effects of schooling it's just even
short interruptions schooling have
enormous consequences in the lives of
children right you have five and a half
one estimate in published in general
pediatrics early independent academics
said that even the short interruption of
schooling in the spring of 2020 would
lead to five and a half million life
years lost for children for in the
united states right because if you skip
school you get you need a shorter
less healthy poor life and i mean you
would argue that particularly with
something like k-12 school
there's no benefit to keeping those kids
at home yeah there really isn't i mean
there are
if you look in europe
most of europe made extreme efforts to
try to keep schools open they did they
kept schools up and had much more normal
schooling than than that we had in many
parts of the united states
and uh it they didn't have worse covered
outcomes as a result and there's a good
reason which is that
for uh for reasons we still don't fully
understand children are less efficient
transmitters of covid
when they're sick than adults are
an early study in iceland
where they did contact tracing and
genetic sequencing the virus found that
uh it's very rare that a child passes
the disease on to a parent but very
common to the other way now it can't
happen of course it's not zero and it's
not as bad if it goes from an adult to a
kid because the kid isn't going to be
harmed in the same way and you're saying
it doesn't really go from a kid to an
adult it can but it is rare yeah and so
you know because one of the arguments uh
that comes up in in the context of your
work um is well teachers are older
people and like what how how would you
create a school space where kids are
there but the teachers aren't yeah so
there's a couple of things like so in
the early days of the pandemic there was
a study done out in sweden sweden they
they kept schools open it was normal
school no mass no social distancing uh
for uh for eight i think for like
secondary for primary school secondary
schools i think you had sex closures um
the the uh there were no
uh child deaths and the teachers
actually had lower covert rates than the
community at large the schools were
safer places to be than the community at
large what would explain that because
they're hanging out with kids
with kids yes okay but but i'd say one
of the things
once we understood that the disease was
aerosolized right we should have we
could have made investments in um in
in changing
ventilations or things like that i mean
instead of like the the sort of the
performative nonsense we invested in we
we could have actually done things that
would have made a difference in public
spaces like schools right
why didn't we
because i mean we were throwing a ton of
money at this stuff and like everywhere
i go i you know i live in new york city
and you still i walk into restaurants
where everybody is in like their little
adolf eichmann you know kind of trial
glass booth or something like that so i
mean we spent a lot of money on this
that actually made things worse
of course i mean that kind of seems
obvious but yeah it's funny when you
walk down the street and you just see
people in there like individual pods
breathing on each other but why didn't
we i mean i i know some people who do
the science of ventilation and they were
screaming from the top of their lungs
all through 2020 that this is what we
need to invest in
a lot of the the conversation that
should have happened among scientists
did not happen
the conversation about covet and what
right thing to do was controlled by a
relatively small number of scientists
who created an illusion of control of
consensus
on all of the mitigation measures they
wanted
without letting in other voices
in fact if you spoke up you were you're
essentially marginalized i mean they
were like for me in particular i can
tell you there was a
a problem in a sense a propaganda
campaign waged what does it mean to be
marginalized in that context because you
also on a certain level you were a
well-respected
uh you know uh doctor of public health
and medicine you have an economics
degree you're at stanford and now you're
extremely well-known so what does it
mean to that you got marginalized
through this process yeah so let me
maybe i can go back just a little bit
about this so so about my my activities
during the pandemic um so i i started
uh
doing research on the hammock in the
very earliest days of it um i worked on
a study
where i was trying to measure the number
of people in l.a county and in santa
clara county that had evidence of
antibodies to covet against covet in
there and their bloodstream is like in
april of 2020.
i thought i was doing science i thought
i was just doing i thought i would
publish a paper
i thought it was an important paper it
would maybe in foreign policy but i
didn't i didn't i didn't realize i was
going to end up in a in the public
sphere as a consequence of it
as soon as we published uh a preprint of
that of the paper in santa clara where
we found that but like three percent of
the of the of the population santa clara
county had center of california had
coveted in april of 2020.
there were a series of hit pieces done
on me and my family
i they were they were like what was so
threatening about that finding
uh so
three percent sounds like not such a big
number yeah but in april 2020 that's a
huge number because what that means is
we can't stop kovit from spreading
everywhere it's already out uh there's
no within a respiratory virus like this
it's not possible maybe when you're near
zero you can suppress down to zero but
the you know if you go back to april
2020 it was like we've just come out of
the most severe lockdown there's still
like nervousness about okay can we have
another one schools were closed uh there
were still businesses businesses are
still closed in california you can't go
back to the people still aren't back in
the office
um and and so
that
idea that the things that we're doing
will will not actually ultimately result
in a good result i mean it's not going
to make covert go away that was the
implication of the study
the other thing that it did is it
implied that the death rate was
relatively low it was i mean now the um
the death rate we got in the study
infection fatality rate was point two
percent in the community
um it's higher in in like nursing homes
and stuff but we just did the community
um uh that number was ten times lower
more than 10 times lower than had been
reported by the world health
organization now they were reporting the
case fatality rate which is a different
epidemiological quantity but people
think that the case fatality rate is
based on the people that you know that
have
actually you can uh say have the disease
and get it right yeah and back then
there was not so much testing available
and so they people were testing people
that would come to the hospital with bad
symptoms
um and while at the same time it was
circulating community with right with
many people who had less bad symptoms um
you know there's a range of outcomes so
they i mean they were essentially only
testing you only could verify somebody
who had a really bad case so the
fatality rate's going to be higher than
the population in general that might
have the disease right and the world
health organization said three three and
a half percent something like that in in
february 2020 there was a paper
published in gemma general of american
medical social saying that like three
percent of the people who get it will
die yeah i mean which is catastrophic i
mean that's just it's you know
where is the infection fatality right
now
it's lower without so uh yeah so it's i
i haven't seen a recent uh recent
estimate the uh professor johnny andes
who's a very famous epidemiologist at
stanford and a friend of mine who worked
on the study with he's also very
demonized in the in the popular press
yeah smeared all kinds of hit pieces
written about even though he's probably
the world's most sighted living
scientist
uh for good reason he's incredible
incredible man um but he uh
he's did a an estimate of of a hundred
of these serial prevalence studies have
been done in 2020 and that's where we
get the point two point two five percent
something like that worldwide
it depends on age though that's the most
important thing
children
have a very low infection fatality rate
whereas uh older people have a much
higher
infection calorie especially if you have
many chronic conditions with omicron it
seems to be lower uh i mean i think the
case fatality rate is about
70 percent lower than omicron than it
was with delta
um
well let's uh talk about the great
barrington declaration because that's
that you published along with two other
co-authors
in um in october of 2020 and this kind
of really crystallized your thought and
a line of dissent
and
explain what the great barrington
declaration sought to do and what the
focus on um or the or the emphasis on
focused protection meant yeah so so
there's really two key scientific facts
underneath this uh
we can talk about a third but really if
you just need these two first
you need to know that there's a huge age
gradient in the risk of bad outcomes if
you get covered right so roughly
speaking for every seven years of age
you double the infection fatality rate
uh before omicron i'm 53
my infection of calories is something on
the order of 0.2 percent so 99.8 percent
survival if i get infected in fact i got
covered and i'm still here um
uh the the that's without the vaccine
with the vaccine that reduces the the
risk of severe outcomes by tenfold right
so um
you have uh so it's point two percent
but for every seven years of age you
double it so if your point if you're 57
it'll be you know point four percent if
you're
64 it'll be 0.8 percent it just goes up
exponentially and if you're a child it's
the survival rates you know well north
of 99.999
right like it's it's very very so that's
the first fact
big age gradients the single most
important risk factor in this disease
for bad outcomes the second thing is
that lockdowns are really harmful
they're harmful for everybody
you skip
you skip getting your cancer screening
it's just bad for your mental health i
mean one in four young adults seriously
considered suicide in june of 2020
according to a cdc study
right so you have this like
multi-dimensional problems caused by the
lockdown including deaths like we talked
about the starvation deaths
abroad
in poor countries
you put those two facts together it's a
simple economic right so if you lift the
lockdowns for the young younger
population the less at risk population
you're
that you're doing them a favor right
right you're actually giving the best
that you avoid those harms now they may
get more they may get more covered
that's possible that's possible but you
know you're not forcing them to expose
themselves they don't want to but they
might that might happen but the harm
from covet is much less than the
lockdown arms for them whereas for older
people especially people living in
nursing homes the lockdown harms are
much worse i'm sorry the coveted arms
are much worse potentially right so um
for them you you should be protecting
them like that's that's where our all
our policy thinking should be should be
it should have gone in the first place
um so that's the great parenting
declaration focused protection for the
older population
and lifting the lock down
you know i've read a series of critiques
of the document and
the ones you know some people are like
oh you're just crazy or you're in the
pay of you know some dark overlord or
something like that i think we can kind
of you know not worry about that too
much well that's also not true
paid zero for it but yeah um but you
know a lot of people said you know just
pragmatically or logistically focused
protection is impossible um
is that true or like what would it what
would it look like because the document
itself you know is kind of makes sense
in a manifesto or a short document you
don't go into detail but
you know didn't we put old people we
took them out of society and put them in
nursing homes where then they died in
massive numbers yeah so um maybe we can
divide this conversation into
pre-vaccine and post-vaccine okay
because i think post-vaccine it's so
it's it the vaccine ends that
conversation right you use the vaccine
preferentially in all people and you
protect them against severe disease
which is that's a form of focus
protection right um
before the vaccine
uh one i'd like maybe you can like i can
highlight how how problematic how how
our react response was by and and what
caused it by going back to
why like in nursing homes in march of
2020
right so in march and april 2020 in new
york in quebec in stockholm in a whole
bunch of places
covet infected patients were sent back
to nursing homes
now why do we do that in new york
we did that because we had the idea that
we had to protect hospital systems
like we looked at we looked at italy we
saw the overburden hospital system we
looked at what happened in in china in
and we said okay we have to avoid the
overburdened hospital systems at all
costs
that's that idea is what led governor
cuomo to send
infected patients cover infected
patients back to nursing homes you
wanted to clear up the hospital systems
if instead the right id if you
understood what the right constraint was
the right constraint was protection of
the vulnerable
he would never have done that right it
was it so if you if you if we oriented
ourselves toward protection of the
vulnerable rather than all these other
goals suppression of the disease in the
community
or or protection of hospital systems and
whatnot we would have had a much better
outcome now
where would the old people where would
the older people who were infected go
would they stay in the hospital and just
be quarantined or isolated or when they
go to some third space they probably
they should stay in the hospital admit
because hospitals have much better
systems for
making sure that patients don't affect
each other
i think
if you think about
how to do it how to protect the old
people before the vaccines it's a very
local problem so in the great branch
declaration faq we had a whole bunch of
suggestions
what i was hoping to happen was that
that this would lead public health
people local public health should like
creatively think about how to help
protect old people where they live in
their own community
right so if you're if you're talking
about
a slum in mumbai it's almost impossible
but fortunately there's not so many old
people there um but if you're talking
about you know uh billings montana
you you know all people living in
essentially like with with their spouse
in in
single-family homes
you have you have a set of things you
could do you could for instance uh offer
uh offered uh to have uh
ubereats delivered to old people or if
you don't want to do reach you can just
have to tell people if you have an old
neighbor offer to go buy groceries for
them things like that where you can
involve the community um in
places like downtown l.a or l.a where
there's like multi-generational homes
it's a little harder but even there you
can be creative right so you offer up
hotel rooms so if if grandson comes
comes and says grandma i think i got i
might have been exposed
grandma calls the public health official
they offer a hotel room for a couple of
days until you make sure that the
grandson's not exposed why do you think
the
scientific consensus
formed so quickly and so you know kind
of rigidly about this is right and
anything that you or other people were
saying is just not even worth discussing
so i think um so i've actually read
through a whole bunch of these these
foia emails that uh the tony fauci and
francis collins and others had in the
nih i mean they were they were the
architects of this policy
um the the the early days of the
pandemic were like a really mystifying
thing right it was it was unclear
exactly how the disease spread it was
unclear exactly what to do
and in fact if you think back to january
february 2020 they were arguing for for
like the public health establishment was
that arguing for something like focus
protection they're wiring you against
extreme measures right the observation
that china
seemed to control the spread of it had
an enormous effect on the minds of of
the public health officials so like for
instance if you look through the fourier
emails
tony fauci and the nih worked very hard
to make sure that this uh that that the
nih official was
got to go to china and observe
he came back and wrote an email that
said to to that said look we have a very
difficult decision to make it looks like
the chinese strategy of lockdown worked
same time you're looking at italy and
it's a complete failure right their
hospital systems are overwhelmed you
have coffins of old people lined up in
in nursing
in in cathedrals
uh it looked like a disaster
and so
i think that switched people's minds off
they said they said okay we have to do
what china did we can get suppression we
can get down to zero let's just do that
and that was even with the there was
those early you know clips of video went
up from china where people were being
like nailed into their apartments and
things like that yeah i mean that's that
was that was that was the difficult
decision right so
can we as a free society
adopt that strategy which looked like it
worked yeah and it did not work in china
uh well i think i mean we don't really
really know like you're looking i'm
looking at the what's coming out of the
images coming out of shanghai now
and it's clearly there's something going
on there right there was something going
on there wuhan i mean so it's possible
that they suppressed it very low almost
all of east asia and all a lot of asia
actually had low levels regardless of
the policy right japan had
minor mitigations relative to what and
yet they they had very low rates china i
mean i
of course had draconian
restrictions and they had low rates so i
think it's possible like there's
something about east asia that at least
until omicron protected it against the
the spread of the disease in the united
states can you point to you know a
particular state i mean kind of along
that line of like a lot of what we seem
to be doing was kind of a
pseudo-scientific or kind of
superstitious behavior like we think
this was this will work so we're just
going to try it is you know can you is
there a meaningful
difference of approach that is evident
in the u.s that shows up in you know in
death rates yeah so if you look at
age-adjusted death rates a place like
florida which actually had relatively
minor mitigations kept schools open
has almost almost exactly the same
age-adjusted coveted death rates as
california
same thing with like age-adjusted excess
mortality roughly the same
roughly the average so does that suggest
that there wasn't that much we could do
i think i think that the suppression
measures that we adopted were not not
particularly effective i mean you can
you can also do comparisons across you
know in europe
and in similar in similar situations
again there's the correlation between
the measures we adopt like the most like
very severe measures we adopted state
home orders business closures that
doesn't seem to correlate with better
outcomes um it's just it it's not that
it makes it worse i mean because it just
doesn't make it better i think and i
think it's important to understand why i
mean so why why is there not a
correlation because it's it's such an
intuitive thing right like you wanna you
wanna if you keep people apart from each
other they can't spread the disease to
each other why doesn't that work right
um i i think it has to do with how
society actually works how it actually
functions right it doesn't function
it's not it's not like we can we we
actually could be apart from each other
we we're not all equally able to stay
apart from each other right so
um there was a study done uh by some
economists uh published in the national
bureau of economic research
that found that only about 30 of us jobs
could be replaced by work from home
so that means if you weren't in that
class you had to work right you had you
had to the the the option to stay at
home and stay safe was was actually a an
upperclass thing a laptop class yeah
well and clearly the people who were
writing about all of this were people
who could work from home which i know i
i'm sure i'm not alone in this but in
the early days the you know the the
fierce urgency of whenever among
reporters and journalists writing about
this it's like we should play it safe
you know we you know this is
uncomfortable but we can do it but it's
like i don't know if you're like a
grocery store worker you don't have that
option but yeah so you weren't writing
the story i mean that's the thing it's
like the grocery store worker that's 65
years old they're essential and they're
asked to go get exposed to covet even
though it's a really high risk for them
yeah i mean a focused protection policy
would say okay well let's give them
sabbatical time right uh or something
some some leave make help them not have
to be exposed while asking young younger
workers to take their place or something
how much i mean you have training as a
medical doctor and as an economist does
that put you in a different
kind of methodological framework than a
lot of public health people
i think so yeah i mean i think a lot of
the a lot of the public health thinking
doesn't at least it seems to me during
the pandemic seem blind to the harms the
opportunity costs if you will um
whereas i mean my just about my like
it's built in my dna is i'm going to be
looking at and thinking about
opportunity costs and harms just
no matter how attractive the policy it's
always the question is relative another
alternate policy
would it be better you know within the
public health community where people or
people seem to be taking cues either
directly or indirectly from
tony fauci and francis collins
you in these emails that you mentioned
the foid emails you are singled out as
you know by name
as a problem that needs to be resolved
how does that make you feel uh you know
just as i mean you're a successful
academic you're a serious intellectual
researcher and you are emerging on the
world stage and two of the most
powerful influential revered respected
science bureaucrats are saying this
guy's nuts yeah it was
it was really frankly it was just
disappointing
right because what i had expected from
them was serious engagement
because i mean there's no way with one
two or three people could just could
actually
know how to how to like set
all of the details of focus protection
policy it's too complicated a problem
needed the all hands on deck
in the public health community so it was
frankly just disappointed to see
them react as if it was a challenge to
them as it was as i was trying to like
show them up rather than trying to
actually improve the outcome
um and uh
i mean i think uh
it was that i mean
to see them write that i i actually
admired tony fauci before the pandemic
he wrote a a textbook on internal
medicine which i still have on my
bookshelf
francis collins i've admired for for a
long time um and to see them behave in
this way
uh essentially like
i mean i don't know about like better
words like such like mob bosses like
they were they were trying to
push us me martin kuldorf who was a
harvard professor at the time and
cenatro gupta oxford probably the
world's best epidemiologist uh at oxford
university to the fringe they literally
called us fringe epidemiologists
um it was a tactic in order to create
this illusion of consensus
that that didn't exist yeah that they
wanted to make people think that their
ideas were so rock solid
that their strategy was so rock solid
that there was no there no opposition
could be reasonable this you are among
the many things you are you are not a
psychologist but and so this might be a
question that you can't answer but
why was that like why were they so
convinced that they knew they were right
like this was past the point where we
should be talking about this stuff it's
a time for action and it seems to me it
kind of mirrors the way the fda and the
cdc early on
in terms of testing and in terms of you
know both of uh you know who who gets to
test but then also who gets to produce
tests like they
flexed really quickly and said no we are
in charge here i mean it's you know
like kind of fanatical control that
turned out to be completely
uh incompetent and disastrous is i mean
is this is this something about like a
scientific bureaucracy is it something
about personality types were people just
freaking out
i mean i i've had a range of ideas about
this i don't know the full answer to
that but i think part of it is that uh
francis collins and tony fauci have been
at the head of this bureaucracy this
enormous nih bureaucracy for a long time
tony fletcher for 40 years i don't think
he has very many people telling him no
and people um like most people don't
know about this but like if you if you
want to advance
your career in biomedical sciences you
need to get nih funding you need to have
uh the imprimatur of the right because
that all all other grants and et cetera
are tagged to that it's it's kind of
like the starter grant well it's more
certainly more it's like it's very
prestigious like at stanford for
instance where i work for a long time if
if you wanted to get be promoted to full
tenure as a in
in the medical school you needed to have
a large nih grant it was a marker of
success
and so uh you have somebody who's been
in that position for 40 years people
never told him really told him no in
fact they they want they they
essentially suck up to him um and you
can see this again in the foia emails
even some of my colleagues written like
this um uh and it uh it must get to your
you must you must think you're right all
the time and i think that's i think
that's part of it the other part of it
is that they had pushed these lockdowns
in the early days of the pandemic
it wasn't working
and but they wanted to make sure they
they wanted to like keep keep going
maybe if they tried more they could
double down more it would work next time
i mean there's some some there's some
element of that right going because
you're just this sort of sunk cost
fallacy is there a way to identify the
moment where you know one among the many
things about this whole
experience is the lockdown itself and
like the the decision to go like we are
throwing a kill switch on the economy we
are keeping people at home we're closing
schools etc
basically unprecedented you know because
even during the 1918 flu epidemic it
wasn't quite that
centralized and draconian
why did we lock down over this um you
know it i mean that is kind of like the
the sixty-four thousand dollar question
i mean i think there's there's some both
supply and demand kind of things that go
on so so for instance i think uh if we
didn't have zoom and we actually didn't
have thirty percent of the
of the
more sort of elite workers being able to
work from home without losing their job
we wouldn't have locked down i think
that's why we didn't lock down in 2009.
that technology didn't exist
um so in a sense i'm sorry in 2009 yeah
in 2009 only h1n1
yeah or in the earlier like in the late
60s or late 50s with flu pandemics
there's there's this is that this is an
unprecedented move right and i think so
it's because we could lock down yeah i
think i think that that that we had just
the just the technology enough to
protect essentially the laptop class and
because of that we we could the other
the other thing was these these models
um
that that were put out but like for
instance the imperial college model in
the early days the pandemic played just
like the chinese example of lockdown
seemingly working played an enormously
important part in the minds and that was
the neil ferguson team that came out
with ultimately kind of debunked
estimate of it was going to be millions
and millions of people in the u.s if we
didn't do something it was i mean it was
not just millions of people it was the
millions of people over the next couple
of months right and and these models
again they're just they're like if you
ever play the video game sims they're
just they're like they call agent-based
models they they agents interacting with
each other randomly yeah um they were
built on parameters it's not that
they're necessarily bad models of this
per se but they're they're built on
parameters that were not known well at
the time there were a lot of uncertainty
about those parameters and the other
thing is that they're they're um
they if they have this feature where
automatically if you keep people apart
inside the sim they're not going to
spread the disease they don't they don't
really reflect what society is like um
and of course i mean famously both neil
ferguson himself who was kind of going
out and
uh circumventing lockdown so that he
could engage in an affair and boris
johnson who put the lock down in order
you know also was caught kind of
cheating on this yeah
i have a lot of that's like almost two
on the nose right i just well i just
have a lot of sympathy for them they're
having like number 10 is having parties
you know though
it's just i i have a lot of sympathy
like we
humans actually have this need to
interact
with each other so you have sympathy
also for governor gavin newsom believe
it or not
i mean i i think i might have envy i
don't know if i have to say but yeah
well i mean i don't i'm pretty angry at
him about keeping my kids out of school
for a year and a half but i do look for
that even that i have some sympathy i
mean i think i think we actually have
this need for human human engagement
human connection
um that even though it doesn't
show up in our death statistics it's
quite important yeah
um
to go back briefly to the uh focused
protection one of the other critiques
was that
somewhere you know estimates are
somewhere between 30 and 50 of the
population
need focused protection and then once
you start hitting those numbers you're
locking down anyway does that hold up
for you or how do you yeah so i i don't
i mean so much i wouldn't close schools
right yeah that's like that that's just
a
straight focus
ranked declaration idea so i don't think
that's right like the 30 to 50 number
has to do with i think uh in
a misunderstanding of who's really at
risk
right so for instance um if you are like
we said earlier uh every seven years of
age doubles your your your risk right if
you're if you compare obese people to
thin people obesity is a this factor
that also doubles your risk it's like
aging seven years yeah uh diabetics
right so severe diabetes so i think
there are some younger people that are
high risk
but they're not but they're not the like
the most
they're not and there's some older
people who are i mean they're at a
certain risk but not at a super
heightened risk yeah so i think um again
it's going to be a personalized thing
it's going to be something localized uh
and i don't think that would have been
impossible i think i don't i'm not
making a claim that focus protection
would have led to zero deaths that's
ridiculous
it's too difficult a disease to control
the spread
the argument i'm making is that the
the idea that if we control community
spread we automatically protect the old
protect the vulnerable is not true we've
seen that 80 percent of the deaths have
been people over 65 40 percent of the
nursing homes it we our suppression
strategy did not actually protect the
vulnerable right my argument i'm making
is that if we put more thought and
energy into protecting the vulnerable we
would have done a better job doing it
now that's all this is before vaccines
one you know uh
the um the barrington declaration was
signed in um october or published
october 5th 2020
um vaccines
you know if you knew the vaccines were
coming would you have still
talked about the same thing or how does
that factor out i would have i mean i
think the vaccines make the the make the
great branch election much more
attractive i think but even before i
think there was a try i mean i wrote it
so obviously i think that um
i think for instance the school's
opening in the fall of 2020 and ended
through through 2021 that was before
vaccines that they should have opened
and they didn't in many places across
the us
in fact many places in the world they
didn't open i think
so ideas like that if they had been a
doc if they were the great branding
decoration been adopted schools would
have stayed open right so
um
i think it would have been difficult it
would have taken a little bit of time to
figure out what focus production looked
like i don't think you'd make the
transition immediately to focus
protection would have been you know so i
think it was still there still would
have been some some delay in october
2020 i i mean i i had heard about the
vaccine trials and i was hoping that
they would work out like you know and of
course they did um
but i didn't know right and i think
nobody could know
and so i think the question is like um
we are in a situation where children are
being harmed a lot of poor people around
the world being harmed working class
people
deemed essential even if they're older
are being harmed
those ideas were necessary in october
2020 just as they were in december 2020.
um
you're pro-vaccine right you believe
that the vaccines are real and that they
work and they essentially i mean again
they don't mitigate anything and they
don't keep keep people from getting the
disease but they keep people from dying
or being hospitalized
um
how much of the the kind of failure of
the public health establishment to put
into place protocols that seemed to work
and that made sense and they weren't
constantly double dealing
or talking on both sides of their mouth
how much of that bleeds into vaccine
skepticism because we are in a world now
where like large percentages of people
are just like no i'm never taking a
vaccine or i'm not taking an
mrna vaccine
etc like how much does uh you know how
much did the first few months of um
the official response to covet
bleed into a bad response from you know
once vaccines were available yeah i mean
i think um so
for the vaccine decision you need to go
to december of 2020 and look carefully
at the trials
the the the mrna randomized trials uh
that they came out
the trials
had as an end point the prevention of
symptomatic disease
there's two other potential endpoints
you could have had for the trials you
could have had the prevention of all
infection
or you could have had the prevention of
severe disease
now the the reason they didn't
use severe disease as an endpoint was
because uh it would have required a much
larger trial severe disease is rare in
order to see a difference in severe
disease you need a very large number of
people
that's why they have a symptomatic
infection i don't know why they didn't
do all infection
and but in particular they didn't they
they only tracked prevention of
symptomatic infection for about three or
four months that was roughly the length
of the trial
um
it turns out that shortly after the
three or four months the protection
against infection drops very sharply
right so you get the vaccine uh and
that protection against infection last
two or three or four months not not very
long but the protection against severe
disease lasts a very long time
the trials didn't tell you that the
trials just told you that it stopped in
symptomatic infection for three months
so that the public health authorities
had to make a decision
can we use this vaccine to get rid of
the disease altogether right to
vaccinate a sufficiently large number of
people we get hurt immunity through the
vaccine and we're done
in that case that means we have we're
counting on the vaccine working against
infection spread for a long time
uh or else you're going to need boosters
booster booster booster booster booster
right um
and then you hope that the variant
doesn't escape the the escape the
vaccine or you say okay this works
against severe disease let's use it for
focus protection
the the people like tony fauci people
like rochelle wolenski who was about to
become the cdc director made the wrong
bet
they bet that it could be used to stop
infection and get the disease from
stopping spreading they they continued
on the path that they had had which was
the goal was
suppression of spread of the disease in
the community right and they're going to
use the vaccine for that purpose
instead of using the vaccine for focus
protection um
is there a way that the public health
you know and say the public health
community or authority
how does it get restored because it's
clear you know at every level uh you
know and this is somebody like fauci you
know it has admitted that you know he
said don't use mass because you know and
then use mass and i i was doing that
because i knew the answer but i didn't
want to tell you you know it sounds like
with the vaccines they were kind of
talking out both sides of their mouth i
mean there's you know a real collapse in
trust and confidence in in public
authority and public health authority is
there a way to get that back or what
what has to happen i mean i ideally if i
were if i were the cdc director i would
i would apologize for the mistakes made
because they've been catastrophic and
so evident to everybody
and then work on a real plan so that
these kinds of mistakes don't happen
again i feel like you nick you mentioned
something that's really important right
so it's the credibility of public health
authorities is critically important if
you if you once you've thrown that away
people aren't going to believe you right
so when in in this dance about mass at
the beginning oh mass don't work mass do
work vaccines are 100 effective against
if you have the vaccine you do not hold
the virus you can't spread the virus
those are not true they didn't know
those are true at the time the vac
actually the mask thing it's interesting
that the literature before the pandemic
good
ran my studies said that the mass didn't
work so when when fauci said the mass
didn't work in february 2020 he was he
was actually telling the truth um uh
it's so
that
and you all you also need new people in
charge i mean i don't think that the
people if you keep the same people in
charge who told you these lies that
people are going to believe you but that
but it needs more than that right you
need systematic reform so that that
credibility come back it's going to take
a long time nick i don't i don't know
the full answer though you know what's
the role of somebody like donald trump
who you know has been it was obviously
when he was in office was very
schizophrenic to begin with but you know
he was kind of like okay i'm creating
operation warp speed everything that
happens because of that is my is on me i
get i get the credit but then he was
always kind of trashing the science he
started
trashing fauci he was against the
vaccines now he's for them how does that
play into and and the more broad
politicization not necessarily by
scientific authorities but by actual
political political people i mean i
think um it's easy in the united states
just to look at i mean trump is a unique
figure and i think he the the the effect
that he has on the minds of most people
in public health is is just amazing like
just it's like a
people stop thinking when they start
talking about him um but i don't think
he's the entire like if you look
lockdowns were adopted by so many
countries with right-wing governments
left-wing governments it didn't matter
the socialist
swedish government didn't adopt a
lockdown right right whereas you know
right-wing boris johnson in the uk are
adopting it
it seems to cut across partisan divides
in in very funny ways and brought
coalitions of people together that
didn't exist before that would never
have spoken to each other frankly
what um
talking about mass you uh in august of
2021 you testified in favor of a masked
ban
of
you testified in favor of a rule by
governor desantis in florida saying that
schools could not
um could not uh make mask wearing
mandatory what went into that decision
so
i think that
mask wearing in children
has no
good scientific evidence in favor of it
right there is not a single randomized
study
still that demonstrates any
efficacy of mass worrying in children
for either them getting the disease or
spreading it right um and you know in
adults there's there was there's a whole
range of randomized trials before the
pandemic
that looked at the effect efficacy of
mask wearing um on controlling the flu
and both source control and and and self
and self protection which found you know
very disappointing results
and during the pandemic itself you've
had a couple of randomized trials
one a danish mass study that found
nothing no no effective surgical mass on
self-protection and the bangladesh mass
study which found a
small protection against using
surgical mass and no really no
protection against using cloth masks
when you testified in favor of that were
you testifying about the mass data
because then there you know there's that
and then there's also a public policy
question which from a libertarian point
of view you know i'm kind of like well
for the same reason i don't want a
public health authority dictating what
somebody can do without any kind of
question i'm not sure i want a governor
telling every school in the state or in
the country or whatever
you have to do this so i was i was
testifying on the science right so
testifying that that plus the the other
side of that is also the harms right so
like
there are kids especially kids with
disabilities autistic kids hearing
impaired kids where i think are harmed
by the mass
i think the questions of of um
i mean essentially it's like what level
of government should have a
decision-making power right over over
these kinds of things
um that's a that's a legitimate question
right so like in in science policy
questions often we
look to like essentially federal
agencies to make decisions about you
know like ken's self how can you can a
local government decide not to allow
cell towers right so those are those are
decisions made actually they're made by
you know at the federal level about
while cell towers don't don't correlate
with cancer seem to cause cancer and
there i mean you're you're testifying
that these cell towers don't cause
cancer you're not necessarily saying
whether or not a town should adopt them
or not yeah but the town can't use the
idea that it causes cancer as a reason
to not allow the cell tower in place
right so i mean the this question of
like what level of government ought to
ought to have that kind of
decision-making authority is is an
interesting one i mean it's important
and in the context of mass i don't think
that it really does a lot
in terms of controlling community spread
especially when you do it in kids and i
think there's some harm for me economic
point of view i just want i want i want
what's best for the for the for the
community to look for those kids and
that's why i testified so did you go
through did you mask up at various
points uh you know and not because you
had to but because you thought it made
sense i i mean at um when i when i
visited my mom in july of 2020 i wore a
mask for the first 15 minutes and then i
couldn't i couldn't yeah i just didn't i
mean i just wanted to give her a hug um
it didn't make sense but so i i mean i
think um if i'm visiting a nursing home
i would i would want a high quality n95
mask i don't think that there's great
evidence that it's perfect especially if
you're like we have a beard or whatever
you're like it's it's and it's if you're
not trained to wear it but but i can
understand like
as a tool of focus protection it can
make some sense i'm not against mask
ordering generally you're right uh but i
think it should correspond to the
evidence that should be subject to a
cost benefit just like we do with
anything else um you are also you're
against vaccine passports and vaccine
mandates um you know and i you know when
i hear that i'm like okay that's what i
think walk me through the logic of that
um you know why and i guess maybe start
with the vaccine mandate if if we know
the vaccines are good and the vaccines
are going to reduce the either the
spread or if not the spread the danger
of getting a disease
you know by 99
um why shouldn't the government mandate
that
okay so uh if to take your hypothetical
about about uh you have something that
actually does stop the spread there you
have like a i take the i take the
vaccine then my vaccine protects you
there's a positive externality there's
an economic argument you can make okay
in favor of it right uh now you you have
to like think about more than just that
positive externality it may be that the
the vaccine then causes me harm and so
do i really want to ask me to have i
mean so there's a lot of complications
going to that i i i'm not against
vaccine mandates as a as a as a whole
from a community so i suspect we're of a
similar age where we have a smallpox
vaccine scar somewhere on us yes um is
that you know is that a legitimate kind
of policy based on science to say yeah
you know what like everybody should get
a smallpox vaccine when smallpox was a
thing it's prevalent yeah so i mean i
think i think it could it could be an
argument right i mean i'm not again i'm
not ideologically opposed to that
but in this context nick we don't have a
vaccine like that
what we have is a vaccine that does not
stop disease spread
right and so all
after three months it's the vaccine
efficacy against disease spread
something like 20 percent
um so what you have is then is that the
disease is going to spread anyways um
and so you don't have that positive
externality argument to me that's
sufficient to kill the vaccine mandate
right but but it also is an argument i
know for me and this is the way i was
thinking about it like while my vaccine
protects me i i know if i take the
vaccine i'm less likely to get a serious
uh case of covert so that was the right
thing and then i'm like yeah why
wouldn't i do that it's free right yeah
no i would i mean i i've gone on tv and
told people that it's a really good idea
to take the vaccine for that reason i
mean i think we give people advice that
it will protect you against severe
disease um and tell them honestly like
here are the side effects we know about
here's a subject we don't know about
here's the benefit and people will take
it based on on that right so is that the
same logic for a vaccine passport that
you showing that you you know that you
have this vaccine it's not it's really
an inter it's a personal decision not a
social one yeah exactly and i think
there's actually there's a little bit
more here so um the passports uh
it's premised on this idea that if i'm
in the room with lots of vaccinated
people
i'm safe or much safer you actually can
cause the disease to spread more
like you get uh you get more more
interactions with people that that are
vaccinated thinking they're safe when
they're not actually safe because the
vaccine can spread the disease
vaccinate conspiracy the other thing is
is natural immunity right so uh the
natural immune context what i mean is is
if you had coveted recovered from it
which is a very substantial number of
people in the united states have
even if you're not vaccinated you're
pretty well protected against severe
disease and until omicron you were
protected against reinfection
um so that means that meant that you're
even before omicron you could be in a
room filled with unvaccinated people and
actually be safer
from getting the disease if they had all
been covered recovered than than uh if
then being a room for unvaccinated
vaccinated people right so this
irrational segregation of society and
it's caused this uh you know it's it's
uprooted the lives of a lot of people
who just for whatever reason because
they maybe they're covered or covered
they just don't trust public health they
didn't want the vaccines
it created this two-tier society this
sort of like sense of clean and unclean
which i think public health should never
do right
um are you vaccinated yeah uh did you
get a booster i didn't i got i was i got
coveted and i got i was vaccinated
almost a year ago uh with the second the
pfizer vaccine april 2021 and i got
covered in in august of 2021 and so what
about your kids uh how old are your kids
or uh three kids uh 15 17 and 21. i
don't really want to talk about their
vaccination status if you don't mind it
because okay yeah i guess um if they're
going to college do they have to is it
is it a good idea for colleges to insist
on uh i i don't think that that i don't
think the vaccine mandate is worthwhile
for college students
i think especially for young men the
myocarditis risk is high enough with
their mrna vaccines that to mandate it
for them it should be a personal choice
i i think it could be if it should be
something where um it depends on their
own or their fist their health
conditions right i don't think is there
any way we come out of this where you
know and this is it it gets very
confusing because a lot of people who
are anti-vaccine are also anti-abortion
but then they use the you know it's my
body my choice argument is there any way
in a more consistent way we come out of
this with people saying it is my body it
is my choice and i can i can get an
abortion if i want and i can get a
vaccine if i want and i can you know i
can i can drink or smoke whatever i want
i mean
these are these are complicated
questions as you know i'm sure you know
because uh but uh the the issue is one
of externalities to me right that's the
key question right how and i think
that's something the reason i'm
attracted to that is because it i think
a lot of the questions about bodily
autonomy are very difficult to resolve
they're like deep value questions about
like how you know what whereas like is
there or isn't there an externality
that's just a scientific question i can
resolve just by looking at the data
right now the externalities could be a
complicated thing right so like we just
talked about about creating a two-tier
society of vaccinated unvaccinated
that's a that's a negative social
consequence that people don't generally
think about when when they're talking
about uh you know these these things are
or if um uh you know
drinking and driving right there there's
a clear positive external negative
externality right
um i think uh
but what i've done in my work in my life
is work on trying to understand those
kinds of like clear signs like questions
of fact
often those you clear up those questions
of fact and it turns out the values
don't matter quite as much as you
thought they did right once you've
understood those questions yeah that's
very interesting talk a little bit about
your life you you mentioned you're 53
where were you born and where were you
raised
so i i was born in india i came to the
us when i was four
my my dad actually had he was an
engineer
and he studied in the u.s applied for
the visa lottery
then got married then had kids and then
dragged me and my mom and mike double
dragged me i was actually very happy to
come i remember landing in in uh
laguardia and mike i don't remember
what's called then but uh my uncle my
dad let met me and my brother gave us
chocolate bars i think it was hershey's
i'm like this is a great country
where did you grow up in the us so uh
first in boston in cambridge um
my dad was electric engineer at the
general electric
and then and then in southern california
and you have i mentioned you have an mdn
and a a phd in economics from stanford
how did you end up doing that that's you
know i mean that's a lot of education
and you know i have met many doctors who
are interested in economics or many
economists who
have the desire to become an md i mean i
would always want to be a doctor i love
science i like i love math
and i
in fact i love chemistry
so much i thought i was going to make
chemistry major but i got to i got i was
an undergraduate at stanford i've been
in stanford since i was 18. yeah um i
think you might want to get out and see
the rest of the world i don't know
maybe someday yeah um
it it uh i mean i took a econ class uh
as a general ed requirement i just fell
in love with it um but i still want to
be a doctor you know that and you know
it's
in indian households you've got this
like
ever you've got to be a doctor and then
you can be whatever you can yeah right
so this is higher you in your heart
you're like doctor engineer
everything else so i'm like okay i gotta
be a doctor i told my dad i was gonna
major in economics he's like are you
sure but i showed him like there's some
math involved so he was okay with it um
do you have a politics or an ideology
i mean i i've always thought of myself
as i mean i like markets i'm economist
not surprising i'm center-right-ish if
you but i never cared deeply about
politics
i just don't i i i s my so many of my
colleagues get so upset when you know
they're mostly on the left right um and
i just never understood it i never
understood why they get so deeply worked
up about politics i most of my career
has been focused on
scientific questions
and questions about fact in that
intersect with with policy right it
infects disease policy nutrition policy
with a whole range of questions where
where i don't know the answer before i
go in
and so i've tried very hard to like keep
that the that out because i don't i
don't i i really like
i like learning from the data i like i
like
it it makes me happy when i have a
result that i didn't expect
and when i write a paper
i honestly can't tell who's gonna
be happy about it or not i mean that's
what's made me happiest in my life in my
career
um the politics you know it's it's it
just it seemed always seemed like
entertainment to me frankly like it
seemed like you know there's two teams
that are fighting with each other um
i am attracted to to uh
ideas where where where more where
they're like there's markets and
decentralized solutions but i also
understand where you sometimes need you
know like i think there ought to be an
nih i just don't think the nih director
should play a big role in health policy
because that if you have an nih director
that does
they they control the minds of so many
scientists that there's an inheritance
and nobody's going to really speak
nobody's going to disagree with them
because that's the cash cow right so
yeah so it's just i think i just i just
i think it's dangerous to but but that's
dangerous but i think i think um if i
have a philosophy it's it's it has to be
it's there's there's gonna be some some
some role for regulation there's gonna
be some role for for markets but those
are going to be determined mostly i hope
by answering factual questions
do you what what are the positive
outcomes from
you know the pandemic and obviously
we're kind of over it but we've also
been here before
you know one of the things that seemed
to happen early on i remember i guess
was massachusetts waived a bunch of its
licensure laws for nurses and doctors
because they needed help and so they
were not going to make people pay a
bunch of money and sit through a bunch
of meaningless tests in order to
practice medicine there i don't know if
they're going to continue that but i
mean are there good outcomes
from the experience that we've had so
far i think like i think telehealth has
won i mean the development of
technologies to actually practice
medicine right
which we've been talking about for
decades now but that finally made people
okay we're going to do this yeah and and
you know that
the vaccines um
as much as i think i deplore the fact
that they were used as a met as a like a
way to like coerce people and they'd
look really
you know people have like lost their
jobs over over this
uh the the the the fact that the
scientific community can come together
and produce something like that in such
a short time is actually quite an
achievement yeah it's amazing because
what how it took years to even isolate
what was causing aids and the
coronavirus was sequenced and the
vaccine was basically put into place in
a few months and it probably could have
been quicker right
i mean it was it was really a remarkable
achievement i i when the uh when covet
the epidemic first started i didn't
think i thought it would take a you know
a long time yeah people were talking
three to five years or longer yeah um
and i guess also you know for all of the
talk about vaccine hesitancy the
adoption curve of of the covet vaccines
is remarkably fast much quicker than mmr
or or polio and things like that i mean
where people are panicked over getting
kovitz so i mean it's not surprising
that but what i've seen though is that
the vaccine hesitancy which you said
earlier is completely right
a lot of the the movement
that hasn't about vaccines has grown
very sharply in part and mainly i think
because of the lack of the the trust now
in public health
the the the activities of public health
the the the the sort of like uh
overclaiming the uh noble lies has led
to a collapse in trust in public health
people think that public health is
hiding things
that has led not not just to vaccine
like decreased vaccine uptake for the
cova vaccines but other vaccines as well
like including mmr wow um what you know
one of the early fears and i think i
actually articulated this among many
other people but is that okay we have
this situation here and however this
ends this ends but
this really becomes a kind of
demonstration case for the way that the
government or governments at various
levels can just turn things on and off
should we be worried about that and what
are
what are the essential lessons to keep
in mind because we're we're already
forgetting what early 2020 was like you
know in economic terms nobody remembers
what the obama administration actually
did in response to the financial crisis
we have clearly forgotten all the
lessons of dealing with inflation in the
late 70s what are the things that we
need to remember so that we are not just
stupidly replicating a failed response
in the past well i think that there
needs to be a lot more oversight like
actually it's just like a classic
american thing you need checks and
balances
right so what happened is you had a
small group of people
scientists very powerful
scientists who panicked the the
political class
and the political class then imposed a
state of emergency that's in many states
continues to this day
the the uh if you look at this if you
thought okay with the the judicial you
know judiciary courts could check it
well it didn't for a year
uh the judiciary did nothing
with in face of gross violations of
civil rights um including things like
the cdc's
moratorium on evictions and whatnot well
i mean you know just some of the very
basic thing in my county uh they closed
churches they
they actually didn't even allow home
bible studies right
right we read a story i believe it was
in mississippi uh where a church service
that was done in cars like a drive-in
church service where people were in
their own cars was cancelled yeah i mean
i mean that's a panic it's a that's
panic right and so you know you could
i'm not against working with churches to
sort of have it have the service be done
more safe but i don't but does they just
say look you can't even have a home
bible study
that's just a violation of the first
amendment i think um same thing with
speech rights right so if you if there
were a lot of people
now i don't i'm not um i'm not saying
like twitter is obviously it's not a
government entity but but there were a
lot of uh of interactions between the
government and big tech to suppress
certain kinds of speech
i my philosophy on that is that you if
you think that there's somebody that's
saying bad things or wrong things then
then come out with a response with data
and information to convince people that
that they're saying wrong bad things
don't suppress them it actually creates
an underground where those those ideas
take off more um
i just don't understand that so but but
i mean that continues to this day so i
think checks and balance is the key
thing like how do you um uh when you
have an emergency like this
you have to have a body that can just
say well is this it should should this
be happening like almost like a team b
that says it puts a break on these
things or like forces the team a to say
you you you know this is not right and i
guess that or this is right you know one
of the critiques of of uh trump that was
kind of interesting is that he was not
actually doing enough as president he he
was kind of hands off he i mean he
talked a lot and we had those
daily kind of uh punch and judy shows
but he left it up to the states
and the states did different things you
know florida acted differently than
california in new york and texas but was
it that the you know the the nih the cdc
that these groups were too powerful so
that we weren't really getting the full
benefits of a kind of federalist or
decentralized approach well so uh i um
one of my friends uh scott atlas it was
it was actually was advised president
trump in july of 2020 he was hired by
trump to advise him he spent his time in
the white house extremely frustrated
what he observed was that
uh the uh
deborah burks that was in charge of the
the white house task force uh on uh um
on kobe's response or the medical side
of it um tony fauci uh uh the robert
redfield who was the former cdc director
and uh and the the former surgeon
general they basically had a pact where
they would just if they if one of them
was fired
all of them would resign it was and
essentially was like it made put trump
in this position where he he basically
he thought he was going to lose the
election
if he if he changed policies but what
then then he brought scott atlas in yeah
what he said was what scott told me was
that um that the that deborah burks went
to good governors around the country
showing them cova statistics about about
you know case case rises um
outside of the context of other other
possible policies and scared them
and they responded many governments most
governors responded by imposing the
desired policy of
tony fauci
um
we again were cut we seem to be coming
out of covid uh you know there are other
reports you know both from europe and
especially from china that the next big
wave is coming
but can you
uh kind of scenario plan what what do
the next six months look like what what
does it look like you know at the start
of 2023
so uh covet is here to stay all right
it's never going away it's it's now i
think the fifth circulating uh commonly
circulating coronavirus in human
populations um a very large fraction of
the population has
protection against it either by dent of
being covert recovered or vaccinated or
both
so
we're going to see waves over and over
again there's going to be new variants
again over and over again some of those
new variants may escape immunity uh in
in it's so that you get a big wave of
cases but none of the variants that
we've seen to date and i i don't think
this is going to change um
escape the protection provided against
severe disease given both either by the
vaccines or by by previous infection
so i think it's going to become
something that's just part of part of
our lives it's unfortunate that it's
here i wish it weren't i wish i could
snap our fingers and go back but then
does it become like a kind of like
seasonal flu type situation yeah i think
it's seasonal i think um you know
again very much
whatever i mean right so but i do i do
think i think that would uh i don't
envision us enacting another lockdown
again i think that people now understand
that that didn't work in fact it caused
all this harm
i think the next
six nine
i mean actually the decade is going to
be
focused on
alleviating the harms caused by the
lockdowns right for children for for uh
in health so the real long covet is
going to be these knock-on effects of
the lockdown less than the not not the
disease itself yeah and i think you're
going to still see people who were in
favor of the lockdowns there's i mean
there are fewer of them now um they're
going to come and they're going to
they're going to like point and try to
continue to like make people scared of
covid
[Music]
i mean i think that that is
irresponsible at this point like i think
essentially it's an anti-vaccine
movement right so because it's it's
saying look you still have to be scared
even though we have this technology
that's that reduces the harm the the the
severe disease from it um i think
increasingly they're going to be
marginalized and they should be what do
you do next
uh i
it's been a crazy two years for me i i
uh um
don't i don't there's still some um
elements of code policy that still need
to get cleaned up i think so i'm going
to continue to work on some of those but
i want to work on longer term projects
so i think science needs to be restored
to its proper place i think the the the
conversation the free-flowing discussion
within science that ought to happen to
make science work was was essentially
hampered during covid uh it was very
difficult
i mean you have to like pay a great cost
to speak up and that shouldn't be the
case in science in sciences should be if
you have an idea you say it and then you
know if you're right you're right if
you're wrong you're wrong it's it's not
a it's not like a career ending event um
what happened during covid was if you if
you were going to be speak up you were i
mean it just it was just an
exhausting anxiety you know written
thing um i think that needs to be
changed so that science has restored its
proper has this proper discussion the
other thing i think science needs to
have a its proper place in public policy
discussion
johnny thatcher even people like me we
should not be setting policy right
my job is i don't view it as a policy
making my job is primarily to to do
research uh i can make policy
recommendations based on on my values
and i can make those explicit i can but
the research tells you okay here's what
the death rate is here's what the the
trade-offs are for these policies and
then policy the policy-making apparatus
democracy
as messy as it is then decides how to
navigate those trade-offs scientists
should contribute to that but should not
be put in place of that we don't we
should not have a technocracy which is
in effect what we've had the last two
years
well we're going to leave it there dr j
bhattacharya thanks for talking to
reason thank you nick